disability recognition is
still
complicated in Europe and follow-up so
more so
my name is Caroline sableyrol
I have
Stargate disease that started at the age
of 6 the first years it was
really  complicated since all the
doctors were looking for
all the possibilities that
could exist in order to really find
an answer to the visual problems
then finally it's really thanks
to research there is the discovery of the
gene that mutated that we were able to  really
detected and give a name to my pathology
of course we are confronted with many
difficulties
in everyday life
but that this difficulty allows us
all the same to gain great strength and
this strength there it is,
it is really
overpowering and that  'you always have to
fight to do what you want and
try to be free with this handicap and
to realize yourself in your
professional and
sentimental and private family life so
ultimately  ent it's a great chance
[Music]